jornada típica en Bogotá y es que el
presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro ha
hecho un llamado a las calles a sus
partidarios estamos junto a la casa
nariño la residencia del presidente que
está separada por la Plaza de Armas del
Congreso y es precisamente en esta Plaza
de Armas donde han hecho el llamado a
Los partidarios y donde también habrá
espacio para un discurso de Gustavo
Petro esta Plaza Hay que decir que
normalmente está reservada para visitas
de mandatarios extranjeros Pero esta vez
sean sus partidarios lo que estén allí
para el que ha sido un llamado para
defender las reformas sociales que el
gobierno Gustavo Petro espera acometer
entre esas reformas seguro que habrá
espacio para la reforma a la salud que
fue radicada en el día lunes y esta
reforma Busca que en el gobierno Busca
que haya una mayor preponderancia de la
atención primaria y también una
transición de un modelo privado a uno
más público habrá espacio seguro también
para las reformas pensional y laboral
que se esperan aprobar en los próximos
meses y a la reforma a la Justicia con
la ley del sometimiento con la que el
gobierno ha Gustavo Petro Busca poder
negociar con estructuras armadas
dedicadas al Crimen y al narcotráfico ya
que con estructuras armadas de origen
político Ya están negociando como es el
caso del ejército de liberación nacional
el eln la guerrilla activa más antigua
de América Latina con la que el lunes
empezó un nuevo ciclo de conversaciones
en México y esperan que en las próximas
semanas se apruebe un cese al fuego esta
convocatoria de reformas irá acompañada
el miércoles por protestas de la
oposición precisamente contra estas
protestas por lo que tanto Este martes
como el miércoles servirá para medir la
temperatura en las calles de cómo están
los colombianos respecto al gobierno de
Gustavo Petro y también será la antesala
meses de campaña electoral para las que
serán las elecciones municipales de
octubre al las alcaldías ya los
departamentos